Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's mal einen Blechkuchen und zwar einen mit Früchten, total frisch
trotzdem so ein bisschen orientalisch angehaucht
weil ich da eine richtig tolle Zutat rein gebe, das verrate ich euch aber gleich.
Ihr müsst natürlich dran bleiben! Wir machen jetzt zuallererst den Boden
und dafür habe ich jetzt hier die Küchenmaschine bereit.
Wenn ihr keine habt, dann nehmt bitte euer Handrührgerät.
Wichtig ist halt, dass wir wirklich die Eier, die ich jetzt schon mal rein gebe,
komplett hell-cremig schlagen.
So, die Eier sind drin und da gebe ich jetzt auch noch Zucker mit rein
das hilft dass die Masse eben noch besser hell-cremig geschlagen wird
und dann dauert das in der Maschine so ungefähr 4min.
Mit der Hand, also mit dem Handrührgerät würd's so 6-7min dauern.
So, die Eier sind jetzt hell-cremig, ich hab auch schon Vanille dazu gegeben und jetzt
nehme ich einmal den Schneebesen ab damit ich in aller Ruhe meine trockenen Zutaten dazu sieben kann.
Wir brauchen Mehl und Backpulver und das habe ich vorab schon miteinander vermengt.
So, dann verbindet sich das einfach besser und jetzt einfach dazu sieben.
Und dann nur noch ganz kurz unterrühren, also wirklich nur ein paar Sekunden, dass es sich gerade so verbindet.
So, jetzt habe ich hier mein Backblech vorbereitet mit meinem neuen Backrahmen oben drauf,
den habe ich jetzt eingestellt.
Ich werde euch die ganz genaue Maßangabe hier unten in die Videobeschreibung schreiben.
Und da gebe ich jetzt den Teig rein
und werde ihn dann glattstreichen und anschließend verteilen wir Mandeln obendrauf.
(H: Woooow, ein neuer Backrahmen jetzt mit Klemmung!!!)
Genau! Ja, der ist echt toll weil er absolut nicht mehr verrutschen kann.
Gut, bei dem Teig würde er eh nicht verrutschen aber wenn ihr mal Hefeteig macht,
dann geht er ja auf im Ofen und so bleibt alles dicht.
(H: Das ist das Ding!)
M-hm!
So und jetzt backen wir den Boden im vorgeheizten Backofen
bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze für ca. 20min.
Und danach vollständig auskühlen lassen und dabei die Oberfläche mit einem sauberen Geschirrtuch abdecken.
So, in der Zwischenzeit machen wir die Creme und dafür habe ich hier kalte Schlagsahne.
Wichtig ist jetzt, dass alle Zutaten kalt sind, die habe ich hier schon mal in meiner Rührschüssel.
Da gebe ich jetzt noch Quark dazu, ich wollte echt so eine locker-leichte
Fühlings-/ Sommertorte bzw. Blechkuchen. Deswegen nehme ich jetzt auf jeden Fall Quark,
einmal mit da rein. Dann süßen wir das Ganze mit Puderzucker und aromatisieren das.
Und jetzt koommt's:
(H: Jetzt koommt's!)
Moment, ich rede schneller als ich handle! Ich muss kurz zu Ende machen hier.
(H: Jaa, wir sind ganz gespannt!)
So!
Moment, Puderzucker rein.
(H: Achso!)
Vanilleextrakt, das ist ja der Klassiker. und jetzt Leute, jetzt kommt's!
Jetzt kommt...
die geheime Geheimzutat!
(H: Wasser!)
Orangenblütenwasser! Jetzt denkt ihr euch alle, die es noch nicht kennen: "Wonach schmeckt das?"
"Nach Orangen?" Hamza, schmeckt's nach Orangen?
(H: Nö!)
Gar nicht! Gar nicht! Ihr müsst es einfach mal -
Oah, ihr müsst einfach mal dran riechen! Das riecht soo genial!
Ich hol mal kurz 'nen Löffel raus, Hamza zeig nicht meine Schublade, die ist nicht aufgeräumt!
So!
(H: *kichert*)
Und jetzt gebe ich da maximal zwei Esslöffel rein.
Ich mach 1 1/2, ich hab nämlich den Kuchen letztens ausprobiert und 1 1/2 waren perfekt.
(H: Also das macht's jetzt orientalischer?)
Das macht's jetzt orientalisch, einfach unverwechselbar!)
Einmalig! So, einen, den geb ich rein.
Den halben noch dazu.
Und jetzt einmal rühren und dann Sahnefest einrieseln lassen
bis das total steif ist. Und das funktioniert wirklich, wenn alle Zutaten
kal-kalt sind.
(H: *lacht*)
Oh nein, nein ich hab mich verschluckt!
An meiner eigenen Spucke!
Kann ich das retten? Ich rette das jetzt nochmal!
(H: Okay!)
(H: Also man merkt echt du musst was trinken, man merkt's!)
Ich habe echt Durst! Wir haben jetzt Fastentag Nummer vier.
(H: Kiki wollte schummeln, die wollte ihre Schlucke spucken! Äh, Spucke schlucken!)
Geht das?
(H: Ja, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung!)
Naja, na gut! Ich fange jetzt mal an, lass Sahnefest einrieseln
und dann - hoffentlich wird die Masse dann steif und alles, ja alles nimmt seinen Lauf.
(H...meine Schummlerin!)
So, ich hab jetzt doch frische Früchte fein geschnitten, bei mir sind's jetzt Erdbeeren und Himbeeren.
Ihr könnt natürlich nehmen was ihr möchtet. Tiefkühlfrüchte könntet ihr nehmen,
rate ich jetzt aber nicht so weil die verlieren ja Wasser und dann werden sie so matschig
und dann ja, weiß ich nicht. Also ich hab jetzt frische Früchte genommen.
So und jetzt habe ich das untergerührt. Gebt die Creme bis zur Weiterverarbeitung in den Kühlschrank,
das ist ganz wichtig. Und wenn auch der Boden ausgekühlt ist, dann vereinen wir alles miteinander.
Sobald der Boden dann abgekühlt ist, einmal den Backrahmen befreien,
das macht ihr am besten mit einem Backformlöser damit euch auch nichts reißt an den Seiten.
Und anschließend einmal mit dem Tortenschneider in der Mitte durchschneiden,
das funktioniert auch wunderbar.
Und dann haben wir ja einmal das Unterteil und die Mandeldecke.
Und die Mandeldecke, die müsst ihr vorab einmal durchschneiden  schon in gerechte Stücke.
Ob ihr das jetzt ganz klein macht oder mittelgroß ist euch überlassen.
Ich mach das jetzt gleich ganz spontan.
Das müsst ihr aber vorab machen damit ihr beim Schneiden später die Decke nicht in die Creme drückt.
Glaubt mir, macht diesen Schritt auf jeden Fall vorher.
Ich schnapp mir jetzt mein Messer und schneid' das jetzt einmal durch.
So, jetzt haben wir's fast geschafft. Um den Boden jetzt wieder den Backrahmen legen.
Ich hab den jetzt auch nicht saubergemacht, den Schritt spar ich mir jetzt einfach.
Ich spare mir das wo ich nur kann weil Geschirrspülen ist jetzt nicht so mein Hobby!
So und jetzt hab ich's einfach nochmal drum herum gelegt.
Und dann die Creme aus dem Kühlschrank holen und einfach glatt verstreichen
und die Mandeldecke obendrüber verteilen, das war's!
(H: *mit hoher Stimme* Das war's!)
Und dann haben wir's!
(H: *mit hoher Stimme*  Super!)
Super!
Diese Quadrate da drauf zu legen, das ist so ein tolles Gefühl!
Das macht so richtig - das ist so satisfying!
(H: Erfüllt einen, ne?)
Erfüllt aber so richtig!
Naja, auf jeden Fall gebe ich da jetzt noch Puderzucker obendrauf.
Ich glaub wir sind so ein bisschen durch, ne? Weil wir hungrig sind.
(H: Ja, ich hab übertreiben Hunger!)
So! Ja, wir haben jetzt noch eine Stunde
bis zum Fastenbrechen.
Ich gebe jetzt Puderzucker obendrauf und eigentlich -
also die Creme müsste eigentlich eine halbe Stunde kühlen.
Dadurch, dass ich die vorbereitet hab und sie grad schon im Kühlschrank war für eine halbe Stunde,
könnte ich es jetzt prinzipiell sofort servieren.
Ihr könnt die Torte natürlich bis zur Weiterverarbeitung einfach kühl stellen
und die hält sich auch so zwei Tage würde ich sagen.
Und jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken!
Und hinterlasst gerne ein Däumchen nach oben. Schreibt mir doch gerne was liebes,
ich lese immer total gerne von euch.
Abonniert meinen Kanal kostenlos, aber das wisst ihr ja schon.
Was habe ich noch vergessen, Hamza?
(H: Instagram!)
Instagram verlinken wir euch. Gerne auch mal deinen Account, ne?
Und genau, die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen wie immer
in der Videobeschreibung hier unter dem Titel.
Und dann sage ich: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen!
Tschüss!
(H: Ich hab Hunger!)
Ich auuuch!